like this it generally means that
they're heading for water that are
feeding a little bit as they go and
there's a couple more still coming
through that are gonna cross the road
just shortly it looks like a rather
large herd that is coming through here
and we positioned ourselves nicely in
the shade because we're also feeling the
heat and I believe just up front is the
female Fang she's got that but she's
just crossed the road folks and she's
headed into the thicket I dunno if VM
can pick up on her there there you can
maybe just see the Fang like tusks that
was going through the thickets there so
she's now in a nice big herd I'm not too
sure or clued up too much on her history
but I do know that everybody has got a
little bit of a liking to that female
Fang and a very distinguishable task
that is growing very much downward from
them okay folks while we carry on here
Tristan has got some elephants that are
mad bossing we do indeed Ralph it is a
great way to get back into the swing of
things by arriving down to Gary dam and
having Elly's having the best time ever
by being in the mud and rolling around
and giving themselves a really good mud
bath now as Rolf mentioned my name is
Tristan on camera today I've got Fergus
and it's an absolute pleasure to focus
on the back of the vehicle since I
haven't seen him in quite some time now
remember this is live it is interactive
so it's always great to hear from all of
you
hashtag safari live on twitter or
youtube chat if you'd like to get hold
of us but this is the best thing to have
is normally when we have a hot weather
like this it's nice to have the alias go
around and they do make their way
towards watery points and gary dam at
the moment is just a small kind of
little mauler effectively but there's
quite a lot of mud just on the edges and
fringes of the water and it's the
perfect place for Elias to come down and
really have a good mud bath and the
reason why they
this is just too cool themselves down at
the end of the day when it's hot like it
is today they creating a layer on their
body of cool mud that he's going to just
protect them a little bit against that
Sun it's going to cool down the blood in
the ears and if they've got any
parasites on them it allows them to them
find some way to rub up on and pull any
of those parasites that they have off
now you can see that female she's really
is flapping her ears quite extensively
and quite rapidly and the reason for
that is basically just to cool herself
down and especially when they've sprayed
a bit of mud to water they will do this
because that coolness of the madden and
water on the years as they flap is going
to just cool the blood much quicker than
if it dries out and it creates that
layer of mud on there so that's why
she's flapping quite a bit you'll also
notice that they're right out in the Sun
at the moment you would think after they
finished mud wallowing because it looks
like the majority of them are done and
not finished with their baths that
they've had you would think that they
would start to move off into the shade
but after a bit of rain that we've had
in and you know this area flooding with
a bit of water there's a lot of
nutritious plants that have just
suddenly grown and so they're sitting
there and you can see they delicately
removing all little bits of vegetation
by using those trunks and those two
little fingers and they just kind of
roll around and they find exactly what
they looking for and then they pluck
them up but now there might be a little
vehicle that might get in the way of our
shots I do apologise that I think tax is
going to just pull around there we go
that's okay so Texas just moved off but
they are just trying to get all of those
little nutritious growths of herbaceous
plants or any little trees that might be
growing and any nutritious grasses that
are coming up so it's a perfect place to
feed and if they get hots then while
they can come back to the water again
just now and cool themselves down but it
is amazing to have Eddie's around and
I'm so excited that Fang is back I know
a number of you let me know over the
course of the week when James found her
back on Juma and the fact that ralphus
got here this afternoon is absolutely be
wonderful and it's great to hear that
she's in good condition and that she's
moving around so thoroughly happy with
the fact that she is back and around now
what I'm gonna do is I'm just going to
reposition ass Lackey the herd was all
swimming and man bathing and I didn't
really want to try and disturb him too
much I wanted to have a situation where
we could try and see them not bathing
but now that they've stopped my bathing
I just want to go around so you can see
the rest of the herd
there's some more behind us coming in
that's actually fantastic news so I'm
just going to pull off here and there's
a whole massive herd that is just
joining from behind that haven't been
down to the water yet and so they're
going to want to come down and if we
position ourselves right here
we should get a perfect view of all of
these elephants coming together and it's
amazing to watch any is when they come
towards a look at how they start to
break out into a run they get so excited
about the fact that they can get close
to water and they can have a mud wallow
and they can cool off in these hot
afternoons and so they get all kind of
fidgety and lots of noise as well and
look at the reaction now you'll see
these two herds will greet one another
all the babies are being grouped on both
sides are being grouped together
unfortunately there's a few warthogs
that are also being chased so you can
see there's a couple warthogs in amongst
everybody that are wandering probably
what all this chaos is about but babies
all being grouped together herds are
merging and they're busy kind of
figuring out who's who look at them all
coming down together how cool is this
what a way to get back to work and
everybody into the water as quick as
they can
the question exactly but you I think you
said you love how Ellie's I didn't hear
the last part how chill they are the
social there we go thank you so yes
that's the best part about it is when
you get these elephants herds and how
social they are and how they kind of
meet and they greets and everybody
interacts with one another it is the
coolest thing to see especially when you
get to herds that come together because
there's a lot of communication that goes
on and you'll find that they'll go and
they'll try and kind of interact with
one another a lot of the time it is
parts of the same herd so you'll get a
situation where some of these members
are have fractured or for herd and they
actually related in some way and so they
see each other there's a bit of a
greeting and then they spread out again
but look at how they've lined up
everybody's gotten themselves into a
situation where they've got their own
little bit of space the problem is is
that if Ellie's have been mud wallowing
already here it's not going to be really
any water there hasn't been Maddie DUP
by them wallowing and going into the
water and so they all trying to find a
space where they
actually drink so a lot of the little
ones are trying to find areas of water
that is not all muddied up you can see
they use their trunk and they just kind
of flail it's about on top of the
surface tension just to break that to
get to the cleaner water underneath but
it is so cool to see you can see the
other hood that was peacefully grazing
before the Stampede arrived they've just
started going up the hill and away and
they starting to go into the shade to go
and feed and now the rest of them seem
to be following on a very quick drink
and a little quick spray of the ears to
cool down and everybody else is off and
moving and I believe they are more that
are arriving behind us so hello it looks
like all of our gentlemen well one
gentleman at least and a female with a
little one that also going to join the
fray fairly shorty he's a fairly young
bull but a beautiful individual he's got
really nice big thick tusks you know
typical bull swagger that they've got
when they move down towards water they
kind of bounce on their legs and then
the little one that's running to try and
keep up but this is absolutely wonderful
how amazing is this we had a really dry
lean spell with elephants in the sabi
sands for a while we're in Toomer and it
was tough we didn't see too many of the
herds and it seems as though in the last
few weeks they've started to come back
since the rains have arrived and fallen
so the elephants are starting to move
back into this area and it's such a
delightful way to start an afternoon by
coming down to a waterhole and just
having this many elephants all around us
I'd actually like to know how many they
are maybe some of you that are watching
on the dam cam that can get some
screenshots of the whole herd we'll be
able to tell us exactly how many oh yeah
I would surmise that there's probably
between 25 and 30 now I believe a lot of
you are saying that this is a great
welcome back surprise it is it's
probably one of the best outside of tiny
and her Cubs showing themselves as
afternoon this is probably one of the
things I'm most looking forward to
seeing so I always loved spending time
with Ellie's particularly here at Sumer
we get Ellie's that are very relaxed we
get to spend time with them in close
proximity and they all kind of come
around the vehicle it's just the most
magic thing to be a part of these herds
and to listen to them and watch all the
little social nuances that they have in
amongst the grouping it really is a
special thing to do so I'm super excited
to be back and to be seeing this
straightaway it's one of the best ways
like I say to start a working cycle
it will be as good sign of things to
come so there we go figures just telling
me now that is this is something that he
missed the most while he was in the
moral one of the things that he missed
was this proximity to elephants and the
sheer kind of intimacy of the sightings
that we have here so we get in amongst
all the aliens and we were able to spend
a lot of time with them and follow them
around and it really is just the most
wonderful way to spend time is amongst
these big gentle giants
the other thing is about a lot of the
hilly areas because we're in a system
where you know they aren't heavily
poached they're not really persecuted
and we as respectful as we can be about
them they tend to be quite relaxed most
of the herds and we get really kind of
in amongst them and they're they really
are very relaxed with our presence which
is quite pleasant and it allows for us
to have these incredible sightings of
them now you can see the herd that came
down for it rather quickly are leaving
very quickly now they probably going to
push off towards before looking at a
tiny baby at the back you're going to
have to keep up little one it's probably
hard work in this weather to try and
keep up but they're going to probably
head up to some of the bigger warts and
points up north maybe to have a bit of
drink in the muddy water that they've
had here now while I admire our elias
and just spend a little bit longer here
because it's so wonderful to be back
with them let's go back across to print
in the Maasai Mara with something that
the area is very famous for yes we are
with the zebra now he looks okay from
this angle I'm just gonna try and move
on you can see him moving his leg I'd
say he's got away from a crocodile and
he's just turned unfortunately let's try
just get a different angle on him you
can actually see there's a big chunk of
skin that's opened up but why I think
it's a crocodile I can see what looked
like other spots where the teeth might
have embedded into him but he keeps
taking our site around around II so I'm
just trying to see it now we've checked
where scar was
but he has vanished he is no longer
there from where he was this morning so
it was right chair so I was sort of
wondering Lions God you see this injured
zebra because he does look quite sort
when he moves how's that char
don't you turn around before we get a
chance to zoom mr. zebra so here we go
now
can't really see those other spots with
it looks like a croc gripped him but
that's on this other shoulder yeah that
looks very sore shame poor mr. zebra
opens a spooling Lapwing behind him but
yeah it does look quite saw it'll
definitely impede his movement little
bit which might make him an easier
target for the Lions but I think
definitely looks like got away from a
crocodile poor chap shame so I think
I've got one more spot to check where
the Lions might be Andrea you are a
hundred percent correct that zebra will
probably end up as dinner or breakfast
or lunch or tea snack or a brunch snack
for the paradise pride are you guys
thinking about crossing do you not see
what happened to him maybe not I think
there's gonna be a bit of a greeting up
there almost like a herd jogging in
quite nice with their little puffs of
dust coming from their feet I know as he
press they've stopped to have a look at
us
hi Lily who's a bit of a zinger of zero
argument in the background who's six
years old Lily would like so if the
Lions don't eat him will he survive
maybe Lily maybe animals are so strong
when it comes to surviving from what we
would think are such terrible terrible
injuries but they are all very good at
surviving so we don't know whether he
will survive or not we'll definitely
come back and check tomorrow to see if
he has made it through the night there's
a little zebra having a drink okay I
think I've got one last spot to check
for the paradise pride and the musketeer
boys
it is a favorite spot of this I have
seen them in that area quite a few times
oh but it sounds like all the way down
in that South Africa my very dear friend
Tristan is having a storm of a start to
his afternoon Safari so it seems as
though we are not destined to leave
Gauri damn this afternoon because as the
elephant's disappeared now so a tall
lanky giraffe has come down and I'm
hoping that it is going to drink at the
moment it's kind of just sussing out the
situation in giraffe are very cautious
drinkers you'll find they'll come down
to water they'll look around you can see
the elephant in the background actually
just going up over the damn wall there
and so they'll come and they'll look and
they'll just make sure that there isn't
some sort of predator in the area at the
end of the day when they drink they
often are in a very compromised position
they splay their legs right out their
head is down it's difficult for them to
get back up to stand and a number of
giraffe have been killed around water
points and so they very nervous about it
they check they make a hundred percent
sure if the coast is clear before
they'll then start to have a little bit
of a drink now it seems as though it's
going to drink in a different place I
was hoping that I would turn and drink
side onto us but it seems as though it's
going to drink from a small puddle in
the background the problem is is there's
some little little rather than large
Eddie's coming down and so they might
push this giraffe or from the water
there we go typical cheeky Elly's they
often do you do this and there you can
see a nice gallop from the earth that's
very cool
not often we get to see them running so
always very nice to see how the
locomotion works of a giraffe and to see
how their legs work when they need to
try and run anyway now this is just a
splinter off that herd that we first had
when we arrived they were down behind
the dam wall feeding and so they're
going to come in and have a little bit
of a drink in a cool down themselves at
the end of the day they probably haven't
had water just yet they were still
feeding in so it's in our time just to
cool down a little bit you can see that
other ones do you have a bit of water on
their ears and so does that big one
actually so maybe they've come from tun
dam side the trunk itself is quite dry
and the feet are dry which means I don't
think they have a situation where
they've been too
- right now it's probably from earlier
in the afternoon now Palin you're
wondering how many herds I think there
are in the Kruger Park system Palin
that's very difficult question to answer
because the numbers on elephants are not
a hundred percent at the moment the last
census was a few years ago and so we
don't actually know how many herds they
are also it's subject to water
availability food availability because
as water dries out so elephants are
being pushed into areas with with
constant water and the herds then grow
they'll then dissipates when there's
more water and food around and so you
know it depends on the time of the year
but I can tell you that there's believed
to be between sixteen and eighteen
thousand elephants within the Kruger
Park system and that would compromise if
you think that most of our elephant
herds are between 50 and I mean 15 and
30 it means that there is a number of
herds within that 18,000 it's really a
large number so a lot of herds spread
all the way throughout now while our two
massive meandering beasts move off in
the form of giraffe and our elephants I
believe Jaime Patterson has found well
the biggest of those that have sharp
claws and teeth and they were hunting
and she's just crept all the way across
a massively deeper lugar about to use
her claws and teeth potentially on the
wildebeest that are up ahead of her so
this is as far as we can go this is as
far as we can follow her it might be
quite fascinating to witness a hunt from
this distance because we'll get to watch
and see how they worked why I was gonna
say work together as a team but to be
honest with you she's all on her own now
she's got a real problem here she's
stalking these wildebeest but there's an
entire herd of a very sharp eyed impala
up and to the left of her I will be
shocked if she manages to get close
enough to chase those Volda beasts on
this flat flat open area the grass is so
short
okay
Megan it's your call as well this is as
close as I can get so she's gonna run
all the way up the hill
but otherwise yes I think if you happy
go for it another absolutely gorgeous
evening in the Maasai Mara and we've got
a scene from a kind of perspective that
we don't often get to share with all of
you
so what sure what you are watching is
happening right here and right now in
the Maasai Mara of Kenya where a hungry
lioness has just broken away from the
rest of her pride and is sneaking all
the way up mountain towards an
unsuspecting group of valle de beast so
there's some Valle de beast there's some
Buffalo and this are some Impala
antelope as well but she's all on her
own the other lionesses haven't come to
help her they've moved a little bit
closer to where she is but they haven't
come to offer any support now what
you're watching is completely live which
means that you can send through any
questions that you have in the comments
section below and it's quite
extraordinary that technology exists
such that we can share these amazing
moments that are happening all the way
in Kenya with all of you wherever you
happen to be across the globe
- now has to use the land to her
advantage the grass is very very short
there's no cover for her at all and I
suspect as she has embarked on a mission
that is not going to succeed I know she
is very far away so if we just explain a
little bit about why she is where she is
and why we are where we are but first an
introduction my name is Jamie and
afternoon Archie is on camera with me
and in front of us is an impossible
river system it is absolutely massive
there is nothing we can do so I'm gonna
keep watching her but essentially we we
can't really do anything we can't get
any closer to her not without running
serious risk of injury in trying to
drive across there but I have something
else to show you
and remember how I said that she was
without support she is there she is all
on her own but the two lioness is off to
my right did actually get up and they
did move a little bit closer to see what
her plans were and to see whether or not
it was worth of their energy in trying
to go and catch her now this morning
this particular group of lions this
particular pride of lions are caught
three warthog piglets and unfortunately
for them they've got a 13 Cubs to feed
there's four lionesses water piglets
just didn't go very far at all so they
are really really hungry for the moment
she's lying down so she still she's
lying down over there and she hasn't
crypt all that much closer William from
Australia you say that you are loving
this broadcast well I'm really glad that
we could share it with you William
watching all the way in Australia it is
very special that we're able to do this
and of course what we try and do is give
you you know whether it's its animals
hunting or whether it's animals with
youngsters whatever it happens to be we
try and share these moments with you
because it all ties together and tells a
story of the lives of these animals
she stopped there's no way there is all
hold on second line is and the third
line is have now moved down there they
go they're moving she's moving the one
the ones already down and it's just have
a little let's just wait a little bit
longer to see how this works its way out
so we can't obviously now see them my
head's in the way for a start but also
we can't get any closer down there that
these lionesses are not gonna walk up
just along this path excuse me over
there there we go there comes a lioness
now no let's watch how this plays out
because as I said we don't often get to
watch a hunt from this kind of
perspective and it gives us a really a
really sort of broad perspective on the
way that the animals work together now
Tyler you're watching in Japan and you
say that you really are enjoying this
very much I'm thrilled to here at Tyler
I've lost a lion though I'm sure they
were two on the right I mean now I can't
see any and I can only see one over
there maybe one of them stopped
somewhere down there to drink one of
them's definitely gone missing so I
wonder if she's not sneaking all the way
around to try and get it behind the bull
the Beast
it is possible it would be a bit of a
stretch to try and get all the way up
that mountain and around them but it is
possible Karen you say you know that
it's bad but you really hope that they
get to catch them I don't think it's bad
at all the Lions can't go to a grocery
store they don't buy pre-packed meats
they need to eat and I'll show you
I understand of course that you feel
sympathy with the animal that's being
hunted but let me show you something
that might help you feel a little bit
better about the entire situation while
we wait for these Lions to move up
I'll show you something that will bring
those of you that are sad worried about
the the Lions hunting a little bit of
comfort so off to my right there are
some very very expectant little faces
not the cut not people in the car I'm
talking about the Cubs over there one
two three four five six seven eight and
nine of them and there's actually 13 in
total in this pride that we know of and
now they're waiting for mom to bring
them some dinner that's what they're
after that's what they're thinking about
and now bear in mind of course that's
eight out of the 10 times that mom tries
to get them dinner possibly even 9 out
of the 10 times that mom tries to get
them dinner knees sorts of conditions
she's not going to manage it and so what
we're showing you is not a kill what
we're showing you is a struggle for
survival Donnie you say that lions are
just magnificent oh there we go now
we've got two that have popped out
moving up the path I agree Donna Lions
are truly magnificent animals and more
than that they are animals that have the
most extraordinary social structure and
bonds between the individuals it's
impossible to watch a lion pride
interacting with each other bearing in
mind that it is a family unit and not
see just how much affection they have
for each and every single pride member
that of course in turn means that they
work together seamlessly when it means
time to get down to business now she's
watching the lioness that's close to the
wildebeest there is an additional factor
here there are three there are three
lionesses that I can see there are four
lionesses in this pride one of them is
missing and I wonder where she's gone
and I wonder as I always do when I watch
something like this is just how much
these Lions have planned it out has she
been gone a lot longer than I realized
sneaking around these lioness is just
waiting for her to
start from behind the animals I don't
know I can tell you though that I think
that this hunt is going to take a very
very long time in this case the
lionesses really cannot afford to rush
things they're very hungry
and once they scare the animals here if
they don't manage to catch one
everything around here is going to be on
high alert so this is going to be a true
game of patience and I think what that
means for all of you having - having
introduced you to this particular pride
of lionesses and they struggle off for
dinner I think what that means for us is
that we say goodbye to you phone for now
and we say from Asha and myself a very
big thank you but if anything does
change stay tuned because we will go
live with more amazing stories from the
Masai Mara in Kenya
right okay well I don't think anything's
going to change and unfortunately the
darker it gets the harder this is gonna
be fast
so we'll search and we'll figure out
what our plans are let's send you across
to Brent who has found well the
fluffiest of all fluffy antelope so
fluffy and particularly when there's a
baby involved which there is looks like
they've just come down to the edge of
the Mara River for a drink but the
female is very cautiously approaching
the river and making sure there's no
dangerous crocodilians now that there
are less crocodiles in this part of the
river than around the crossings but
there are still definitely crocodiles I
know someone has him a zebra taken by a
crocodile at this very spot I also think
the river might be a little bit okay I
heard something
and false alarm I thought I heard some
alarm calls a little bit upstream but no
slack there we go she's going down to
drink this is a very popular drinking
spot for lots of different animals the
zebra and drink they're frequently the
Thompsons the topi
trap says I love their heart knows
they're hurt and their noses are quite
special aren't there and little I know
you also gonna go drink and you can see
there's a little bit of rain starting
little droplets all in the water getting
quite a pretty scene I can hear some
birds on the other side
Sam would like a puff backtrack just
having a look to see if we can spot it
we can hear the hippos
it is truly pleasant just taking a
moment next to the river and listening
to their the sounds so there's a big
group of hippos we can hear some weavers
dark cap ball ball rattling Cystic EULA
I am a red-eye does I am a red-eyed of
you know the doves calling I see if we
get a view of these weavers and this
acacia next day I hope they don't fly
off when we reverse
[Applause]
mmm
[Applause]
it's I can just make him art hopping
around in the tree top of this smaller
acacia it's very difficult to see I just
healed shot of yellow so with and there
we go and just see it happy I can't see
which Weaver it is I've been here the a
prize again it doesn't want to be on
camera Weaver that's what type of Eva it
is and you can see there's impressive
thorns on the acacia zanthor Illya what
do you spot a jar the thorns yes you
don't want to be walking barefoot under
one of these trees elbows think it's
funny great joke as they are okay
I'm hoping we're not gonna get wet but
we might a little bit arraigned behind
us in a bit around ahead of us but it
looks like there's little bits of rain
we were seeing have stopped
so we shall continue on unfortunately no
luck with Scott in the Paradise prior
today
okay well we see if there's any other
wonders to find in the Mara let's go all
the way down south to Ralph
so folks just a little bit of an update
we've there was some Impala alarm
calling and a couple of the game viewers
spread out and there's been some checks
picked up of a male leopard so it could
be hasanat in ghana Voula
any one of these male cats so we are
trying to help locate these animals and
it looks like they've they've headed
towards the Galago lodge so we're gonna
we going to be just looping around and
just seeing if we can pick up on him on
this animal his some it seems he is
walking around now during the day the
clouds are coming over a little bit and
it's been such a relief every day this
has been happening when it's been
scorching hot and the clouds have come
through a little bit and it's just
cooled things down nicely so hopefully
we're gonna find this male leopard
moving sorry for all the bumps I'm on a
little bit of a bumpy road yeah but
better a little bit further on but
it's one of those days we've just
started out we found those elephants who
are lovely on the move we're moving
towards water now that you you did then
watch some lovely elephants with Tristan
heavy bait toys asking the question what
is the most difficult part of my job
well that's a difficult question is not
too much about my job that I find overly
difficult
I do enjoy most of what I do that's why
I'm here yes I must say that you know
working in the tourism industry I think
probably one of the most difficult parts
of working with people is the people
because we have a lot of different
nationalities we have people from all
over the world we have people that
sometimes don't quite I don't know see
things the way we do so it can be
difficult I think initially especially
as an inexperienced guide that's
probably one of the most difficult parts
of the job to get over I think later it
has come easier to me especially once
I've traveled around the world to Europe
and and also having a lot of different
people coming on the tours and staying
in different lodges I think you get to
understand people a little bit better
but that is probably one of the most
difficult parts especially initially as
a young guard once you get to know
people better in the way that they
generally operate different
nationalities I think it then becomes a
lot easier to handle so yes I think I
think the animals are a lot easier to
handle then people are there are a lot
more instinctive I think and they're not
as emotional I would say so it's quite a
bit easier to to work with animals but
they don't talk as well so it's a little
bit easier to understand body language
etc so yeah quite a difficult thing to
get your head around different
nationalities but eventually as I say it
does become second nature and you know
that French people like certain
things or things done in a certain way
especially around food and the table
Americans might like things differently
you know and the British for instance
like things their way so everybody likes
their own little the own little way so
yes but it's not decided that anybody's
way is the best it's just that everybody
around the world do things differently
so we're gonna continue here along the
ride looking for this lipid and I'll
give you an update shortly in the
meantime let's go over to Tristan and
see what he's been up to well we just
left Gary dam after spending some time
watching all the different creatures
coming down they were some Nala
it was impalas the giraffe were there
and we decided once they all started
leaving that we would also take our
leave of absence and we're going to try
and see if there's any sign of tündi
around yalla it's off now I know Scots
and Ralph were out this morning and they
think that they found where she's been
going up and down and so I'm in the area
just to have a little look so far
nothing that I can see other than an
egyptian goose that seems fairly relaxed
with life doesn't seem as though it's
too upset about anything moving around
in this particular section so I don't
know if she's been moving during the day
today maybe she's at the Dane site
wherever it is and just resting or she's
found herself a shady spot to rest
either way it's worth checking around
here I want to try and see if maybe
she's moved the day and if we can try
and pick up exactly where she's moved it
to nothing that's going to be my mission
over this next little work stunt mister
try and find at Andy and the little ones
there he's the plan anyway whether it
works out or not I'm not quite sure what
is surprising with our Egyptian goose is
that there is only one of them I would
have thought that we would have had a
pair here they generally are in pairs
together very seldom that you see one by
itself so maybe the other one is
drifting somewhere at one of the other
mud wallows maybe a chillip and just
across the drainage on the other side
so did it Tom no nobody has actually
seen Tom these Cubs yet the no burdens
actually had any visual of them
whatsoever and that's why we trying now
quite intensively to start looking for
her and to try and really see if we can
find and confirm if they are Cubs how
many Cubs what the situation is how big
they are whether or not our timing in
terms of what we think how old they are
is is correct and so that's why we put
in gonna put in concerted efforts over
the next few weeks to try and find this
and try and find exactly where she is at
the end of the day something might have
happened to them you never know maybe
she's not dating anymore but the signs
are that she still is the way that she's
moving about and going back and forward
in in similar areas to where she's been
over the last I would say six weeks
he's an indication that she should be
somewhere in this general vicinity and
should still have Cubs we know that she
did have suckle marks the other day I
did ask somebody they said they saw
suckle marks on her so she must have
them it's just a question of whether
they've survived and if there are still
a lot indeed still alive so we're going
to try our very best and to see if we
can find them I am positive I feel like
we are going to find them shortly
Scott's and I were talking about it
today that we try and spend a lot of
time outside of drives even to try and
find her and see if we can spot a some
way in these areas now where I'm going
now is a little pan that's not too far
off from where Scott things that the den
might be Scott said this morning you had
tracks like I say going up and down
quite close to Bethany Road so I want to
just quickly check this waterhole and
see if there is anything at the water
hole itself which is just round this
corner there's some franklin's so that's
not going to bode well for a leopard
it's just check here quickly so no it
looks as though it's all quite quiet
around this little watery mud wallows
this is where I was talking about it is
a section I've seen a drink at a few
times so I thought I'd just come and
check but while I kind of scan or not I
was going to say while I scan the bushes
were you going to go across to Jamie
Patterson but let's just check and make
100% sure first before we do any of that
it doesn't look like anything's here the
Franklin's are sort of walking around
they don't seem too ruffled by anything
they
not squawking or squeaking or making any
noise there's no other birds also making
any noise so I don't think there's any
sign of her in this potential area right
now I'd really like to continue the
search and hopefully we will have some
luck at some points and while we do that
it seems as though Jamie Patterson is
having a far easier time of it and is
managed to find what she's been looking
for so while Tristan goes off in search
of a ton Dee's Cubs we have some Cubs of
our own and they're just were looking so
sweet that I couldn't resist coming to
have a closer look although I am going
to turn around and go back towards the
other lionesses shortly because just as
I left them some zebra started moving
down towards them I'm just gonna keep
looking backwards the reason I actually
left apart from the fact that the lion
cubs are so cute is because it started
to rain so I needed to put my the back
of the car towards the well in the
direction that the wind was blowing the
raining from but we seem to be a great
deal better off now but it's still a
nice moment to just stop and look at the
Lions in front of us
there was one off to the right but I've
lost it now let's keep looking at the
lines on the termite mound let me move
my head out of the way I keep trying to
do a head count to work out exactly how
many are around but it hasn't worked out
so well
ah there's a voice I haven't heard
properly in a while over the radio
no James injury no no no you can go
ahead makes I just I just heard James
chatting to me over the radio I hope he
wasn't actually trying to chat to me
there is the fourth line s moving up the
termite mound she's now responding to
the movements of the Lions behind us so
I think she now knows that there is a
chance that her sister's could be
successful and we are going to turn
around and move in that direction when
she comes past us but we do have a
question from a new viewer about whether
or not we ever worry that the animals
are going to jump into the vehicle with
us or if they are in any way going to
attack us because obviously we're out
here in an open vehicle and the answer
to that is no absolutely not
we're in it we're in no way concerned
for our safety obviously that we don't
get blase about the whole thing there
are wild animals and they are capable of
injuring us however they have grown up
around Safari vehicles they're not
concerned by us at all you can see they
haven't altered their natural behavior
at all they haven't shown any signs of
fear or aggression and they don't see us
as food either now there's no reason for
us to fear the animals that we see we've
also been doing this for many many years
so we're constantly watching their
behavior and we're looking to see
whether or not the Lions are in any way
uncomfortable or any animal actually and
we're constantly making judgment calls
as to exactly where we want to be or
what we want to be doing or two Cubs on
the lift just behind the slot busy
having a little rough were having a
rough and tumble the Cubs aren't very
playful at the moment I think because
they are so hungry
but usually at this time of day you find
that the Cubs become particularly
playful there we go
that's called lazy wrestling that's
what's happening right there that is
lazy wrestling in size of that one's
paws pop on your head
got your head
now Catherine you say that you love this
pride and that you find that the
lionesses work so hard and I'm and yes
they do they do work very hard I have a
soft spot for that for this particular
pride because it's the pride of lions
that I started following from the very
beginning and when I first arrived here
the the middle set of Cubs were still
very very small so I was the first
person to see them and I was lucky
enough to be the first person to see the
youngest set of Cubs and I have followed
them for many many many hours overnight
back in the beginning in fact I probably
have spent well over a hundred a hundred
hours with these lions would that be
excessive no it wouldn't be that would
be about fair take down bristling each
other I would say I've spent over 100
line 100 lines with these hours exactly
totally
I do have a soft spot for them I've seen
them succeed and vales succeed and fail
look at your gorgeous face Hannah at
around about a year and a half will be
the soonest that the Cubs will really
start to be able to participate in a
meaningful way to the hunt and it's only
at around about two two and a half years
old that they stopped messing it up
though they they will participate from
now so the older Cubs are big enough and
strong enough that the lioness is in a
situation where they've caught something
like a buffalo calf or whatever it
happens to be if they don't think that
the Cubs will injure themselves the Cubs
will be allowed to to practice their
hunting skills practice their killing
skills actually if I'm honest because by
then the hunt is over so they have to
learn but they're still just a little
bit too young the eldest ones I keep
saying eight months but I think that's
because I've lost track of time I think
the oldest ones are around about nine
months now possibly even a little bit
older obviously I wasn't here for when
those Cubs were first born have you ever
seen such hungry looking Cubs
ah things I'm so sorry I couldn't hear
that name at all campus campus wants to
know if lines lioness has raised their
cubs on instinct or do they remember how
their mothers raised them or perhaps
have they observed how their answer
raised their their cousins we don't know
the answer to that but I would say that
the most likely luck answer
realistically is that it's instinct I
mean we don't remember things from our
early early childhood and all from when
we were babies and I doubt that the Cubs
do either and that instinct is so so
strong all all essentially all female
animals out here most female animals
have got such strong maternal instincts
and you see it in action from the minute
the lionesses have their cubs and you
can see they look they do learn I think
that they do learn certain tricks of the
trade but you watch them with their
first set of cubs and you see this
almost confusion on their faces as they
stare at these little bawling creatures
as if to say what on earth have I done
what are these what am I meant to do
with them I meant to do them why is it
yelling and then of course they know
instinctively how to pick it up how to
feed it when to introduce it to the
pride not to introduce it to the pride
in the early stages theirs are all
powerful powerful powerful instincts
yeah beautiful yes we're talking about
you that's the last of the female store
there's some really really great free
advertising right there behind the Lions
head
such pretty lionesses what do you think
girl I don't think you think this is a
good effort this hunt I don't think you
think it's gonna succeed man I can tell
you that the Cubs are eagerly awaiting a
good result in fact it almost looks they
look they look like children waiting for
their parents to come over take away
okay we're going to sit this one out and
spend more time with the Angoras let's
go and find out where Brent is
apparently he's bumbling about in the
Mara I'm taking a very relaxed afternoon
Drive this afternoon I'm hoping that I
was feeling lucky but nothing seems to
be popping out for me today but anyway
that's the way it goes we are live from
one of the most incredible places on
earth the Maasai Mara National Reserve
and it is just quite nice to just take
in the scenery in I mean it is
absolutely stunning here gorgeous that's
a gorgeous but yeah I'm hoping I will
find some lions of my own I'm checking
very carefully that quite often the Mara
River pride pop up in this part of the
the park what have we got there nothing
hello viñoly bernard is wondering where
on earth of all the wildebeest disappear
- well there were gone that south well
not all of them the Volta beast of the
main section of the migration I know not
this way
I need that side lines but that was a
long time ago yeah not me I was off this
morning but yet so one of our cars was
there yes the two border boys okay
very nice good safari what we live right
now so everyone's watching right now
we're broadcasting live across the world
perfect well great I'm glad that it's
brought it to the Mara and there's a
nice time of the year to be here there
plenty is gonna look hard okay guys
we'll have a good Drive okay sorry about
that face what does I talking about how
he can you remember
I'll waive all of all the B's
disappeared too there we go that was the
question sorry about that's got sub DP
sidetracked there bar lions and cheetahs
and whatnot but yes so there's basically
two major herds of all the beasts in
this area you have the main sort of the
migration of all the beasts that travels
between the Serengeti in the Maasai Mara
there's about 1.5 million of them and at
this time of the other have moved south
towards the southern plains around in
due to where they will go give birth and
about jamaat's all same and then they'll
slowly start working their way back up
and they should be back in Kenya at the
earliest end of June normally July
however we have about another 250,000
which are currently spread from around
ma Sierra to talaq and into the
conservancies they're called the loiter
herd and they do not leave care they
traditionally migrates to the loiter
Hills which is 100 KS or so that way as
the crow flies and they're [ __ ] birth
are on there however last year quite a
significant number of the Lloyds ahead
did not make the journey to the hills
and they actually gave birth on the
Paradise plain in the Masai Mara so it's
going to be interesting to see whether
they decide to hang about or head to
loiter this yet now one of the problems
that's facing the Leutze herd and one of
the reasons main reasons why they stayed
in the Lamar last year is a fences being
put up for agriculture so it it is one
of the biggest of killers of large
migrations and animal movements it's
often not shooting or poaching it is
actually the fence that'll stop it
okay where is everything not even
Ellie's our chat today I feel like some
Ellie's I don't know she ever even finds
me release
and as I said early I was I was really
happy to find some Ellie's having a mud
bath and well Tristan had the elephants
might do bar thing so have a little bit
jealous of him
but of course you never know what's
around the next corner on a live African
safari
oh I think ah I think I have lost still
yet
I lost comes with Megan but I've got it
back but let's go quickly back to Jamie
and her lines our lines that are posing
so beautifully for us this is such a
rare and wonderful opportunity for us to
see all of the Anne garments together on
a termite mound it's just such a special
image or at least most of them anyway
I might not yet have been able to do
what I was expecting to be able to do I
thought at one point or another we get
all of them walking from one spot to
another and I thought maybe we could do
a quick calculation of how many males
and females are here it hasn't quite
worked out that way because they haven't
moved since I arrived so I'm still
keeping an eye on where the lionesses
are I can't see them at all anymore back
on that slope and unfortunately as it
gets dark obviously it's going to be
harder and harder for us to be able to
see what they're doing our infrared
lights won't reach there there's not all
that much that we'll be able to do about
it
some big yawns coming from the Cubs some
signs of moving quite a few of them
giving each other a bit of a clean or
their own feet a bit of a clean
I fell look so dejected no need to look
so dejected
so I mush riding on those lionesses
hunting efforts over the next few days
okay we're gonna spend a bit more time
with our puddle of lions and wait to see
whether or not the Cubs get up and
perhaps even start playing it sends you
back across a - ruff who has had a truly
special afternoon
surrounded by elephants hey folks we've
been driving along the Milwaukee River
and we've just come across a small group
of elephants that are just enjoying
themselves in this lovely cool River and
vegetation next to the river and they're
feeding a little bit there were two
miles that we're just having a little
bit of a sparring session but they seem
to have calmed down a bit now so if
these elephants start to come towards us
I will be moving out the way of them
rather quickly and you can see them now
and they starting to spar off again I'm
just keeping my arm in because as they
right make the way down towards us I
don't want to be getting in their way
they're in a little bit of a boisterous
mood and sometimes when one can be
pushed around a little bit they can
start to take it out on you so I'm not
going to let them get too close to me
but if they stay in that general area
and we should be alright in it just
starting to be a little bit more
elephants popping up around the area
moving back slack effects I don't want
to get involved in a little scuffle but
quite nice to see them facing off like
that
the Bulls do sort of have this play
fighting and it is a couple of
youngsters that are fighting they've
moved into the thicket of it but this is
all very important for later in life
when they when they when they do become
very big males and they can literally
fight to the death so it's important for
them to learn that sparring techniques
now and it's all in the name of for the
the real-life situations a bit lighter
generally when they're a little bit
younger likeness they're just pushing
and shoving each other around like all
the teenagers would a bit of arm
wrestling and a bit of fun so it's not a
laugh in this situation at present but
there can be a little bit boisterous and
with him being so big if they do make
their way towards us we do need to be a
little bit careful because we're
probably a small sized elephant with the
vehicle and everything involved here and
so it's it's just important is to just
to give them their space that's all now
there's a little young bull here I think
this I'm having the feeling that that
it's a small group of males I haven't
had a chance to positively do a male and
female decision yet but those two that
were flying they're definitely males
they were having another go at each
other it's nice to see them
some relaxed some are pushing each other
around and it's been absolutely
fascinating that so many more elephants
have moved into the area and
straw-haired making the comments some
power struggles going on there I
definitely agree with you destroy hit
and there's a few of them they're moving
towards us nicely a little bit that's a
young teenager he's a lot younger than
the rest so he wouldn't get involved in
the scuffle because he's a little bit
too young for that but he's also
witnessing it and it was a realizing
that that's what boys do it's a learning
even if he's not partaking and you can
see the flapping of the ears that's all
down to this nice heat that we've got
rat facts we're just gonna jump over to
Justin who's got husana for you
we do indeed we've managed to come down
to twin dams and then you can see him
just riding he's crossing over into
little Gary so we're gonna be able to
have him for very long at all but he's
going down towards the bean pan hope
he's gonna have a little bit of a drink
you can see the impalas are shouting at
him at the moment making quite a bit of
noise telling him that they've seen him
and you'll see him partners will
actually run closer towards him like
that when they shot at him just to try
and keep him in sight and keep him in
view and you would think that that
distance would be really really close
and that this Impala would be in a lot
of danger but they are a well aware of
how fast he is and they are much more
feet footed over that distance and they
can get away much quicker than he can
get to them but you see he is st.
marking so for all of you that have been
asking whether or not asana has been st.
marking that is a typical scent marking
manoeuvre first to rub the face the
glands on the face will then cause this
animal to secrete from there and that
won't be a marking and then he lifts his
tail and he sprays urine to be able to
sink in that area as well now I'm gonna
go forward just a little bit because it
looks like he might drink and if he
drinks then we can at least see him
drinking I also just want to get off the
main road because otherwise we're gonna
cause a bit of a traffic jam but it
seems as though he's going in towards
the waterhole al-ahram where you say you
love that cool tell it is the best thing
and it is something that we use a lot to
spot lipids when they curl that tail you
can see how that white really contrasts
the rest of his body
blings in incredibly well but when he
sticks that tail up and is that white
contrasting bits it's quite easy to spot
them but it is the best thing when
they're getting shorter that they lifted
up as almost like a white flag to say
I'm not hunting you leave me alone stop
shouting and I was kind of hoping for a
second there when these Impala started
to shout at him that I was gonna push
him back northwards but unfortunately it
seems as though he's going to be on his
way straight south and off into little
Gary
unfortunately so he was on our side he
must have been around twin dams just
having a rest during the day today and
he's then decided to move off what's he
found they look as though he's gone into
the bush
what's he got maybe he's found a little
tortoise or a Terrapin No
Sharon you say it's nice to see the
beginning of his julep Mercer Tunisia is
definitely starting to drop quite a bit
now you starting to see a little bit of
that fold of skin kind of coming out and
it's looking a lot more like a male
leopard and a lot less cub like as the
days go on and he's growing every single
day you can see it's also got a nice
full belly he's been taking advantage of
the lambing season with the impalas and
has really gone after quite a few
different lambs is that tail up again
marking territory once again
he's just looking as the car goes past I
apologize about the vehicles
unfortunately where we are we can't
really position ourselves any
differently than what we have already
and our view of him is about to
disappear in the next few seconds as he
just goes behind a little Bank once he
goes behind me unfortunately
there's very little we can do to keep
him just gonna travel forward a bit or
maybe back for you Ferg
let's see if we can just keep a view of
him a little bit longer as he meanders
southwards because he is moving straight
off in a southerly direction which is
not ideal but we will store on our tündi
search and we're just checking the
milliwatts e when we heard some impalas
alarm calling and we were told that they
were impalas alarm calling close to this
area so he came to just investigate and
I'm glad we did I thought maybe Tandy
could be moving around at the end of the
day she's in a situation where she would
be looking for water and potentially
maybe even hunting and moving from the
areas where they had tracks of her this
morning and I thought maybe she might be
done
twin dams we know she does come down
here every now and then but very
pleasant surprise to see the young
Prince he's always a welcome sight in
our area but I think like I said that is
the last view we're going to get of him
as he just disappears and watch that
camouflage as he goes behind these
bushes completely disappears in the
space of two or three seconds it is so
good to see leopards again in
particularly husana it's wonderful when
you get back and you see all these
characters again and you get to kind of
sit with them and know there's not been
a very long sighting but it's always
very pleasant when we get to see them so
very nice right well I'm going to carry
on trying to look for tündi in this area
since I'm down here and maybe we'll get
lucky maybe husana will come back north
we'll just keep an ear out while we do
that so let's go back across to Jamie
who's still sitting with the beautiful
and gamma pride I would have been very
surprised if Tristan wandered away from
just having got back from leave and
hadn't found a leopard I definitely
would have been I would have been
shocked to say the least
so our beautiful lion cubs are still
posing beautifully for us and not only
that or even more privileged because one
of them has chosen to come and sit right
next to our vehicle and ankle beautiful
cat yes no she's right up next to us she
went to go and investigate exactly what
the other three lionesses have gone off
to do and to provide an extra layer of
entertainment there's a vehicle that
drove into a hole and is now stuck
we've got all sorts of things happening
here in this particular sighting I keep
checking behind me just to make sure
that the adults haven't launched
themselves after dinner yet I haven't
seen any sign of movement and the zebra
and the bull the beasts are still
looking very calm nothing's happened
nothing's changed yet
still waiting still hoping for dinner I
think what you'll probably find in this
particular area is that the lions are
going to have to wait until night falls
Oh get it get it get the fly I would say
that they without any kind of cover
they're gonna have to wait for the cover
of darkness and it is getting towards it
is getting towards full moon as well
which means that it's going to be even
harder for them during full moon nights
is when the Lions probably have their
lowest success rate of of hunting at
night dachshund now we actually spoke
about this question this morning funny
enough dachshund I was wondering about
how long a lion can last without eating
and obviously it depends on the
condition that the Lions in it depends
on if it's owned if it's a tiny lion or
an older lion but for a healthy adult
lion I would say that they could
probably go around about three weeks
possibly even more but of course there
is a very firm cutoff point because when
they can't although maybe within a pride
they'll be okay but when they can't hunt
for themselves and when they don't have
the energy to hunt for themselves then
even though they could survive for a
little bit longer
they still bent on going to survive if
that makes any sense because it's a
tough world out here and for a lion with
a broken leg or whatever else it happens
to be I have seen lion prides feed
injured members before they don't drag
the carcass to them or anything like
that and they certainly don't
regurgitate like wild dogs do but what
they do I mean essentially the the
injured line drags herself after the
rest of the pride and then they allow
her to to feed with them so it is
something that does happen
it's my back yet she bought us - no I
mean what are those Tufts of hair
sticking out of the side of your ears
they're they look ridiculous I think
you've had a really funny haircut is it
just my imagination does anyone else see
that on that lion cub on the Left those
two little Tufts of hair it's just
because they're so symmetrical as well
it's hilarious what is all of this
hullabaloo huh guys here comes one of
the Cubs the cub let was next to us
let's just have a look at her quickly
because I want to show you what I meant
about the Cubs looking a little lanky
they are looking looking a little
lengthy or they're not she definitely
does okay as our lioness young lioness
sickles down back on the termite mound
let's go and see whether or not a Brent
is still driving about the Mara and what
he's searching for
I am I'm not sure what I'm searching for
at this very moment I'm searching for
anything because there is not a
heartbeat around me there's not even a
timid taupey in sight but we do have a
breathtaking view which I'm going to
show you I'm just going to get into the
right spot
line up a lovely shepherd's tree ah
there we go how's that oh we can do it
little listen to see what we can hear
again then he has some pectoral patch
assisted killers I can also hear
yellow-throated long claw and there was
a bit earlier a red-winged Franklin
calling as well and the cricket
absolutely gorgeous
okay now umka was wondering since there
is a policy of human intervention in the
Masai Mara would the park feed the
animals during a drought um to be honest
I don't know no Joe this is not and Joe
has been in the bar a lot longer than a
sir I am definitely going to say I was
think with Java so no so and and again
it seems to be that the the lions and
leopards and the cheetahs and elephants
rhino
I pretty much what their will
use veterinary service on I can't see
them for example using the vets on the
zebra we saw it today but I'm not sure
yeah I didn't think so
bad yes now on the other hand if that
wound was from a steer I think
definitely then they would get involved
it's quite a an interesting one and I
mean everywhere it's different
and I'm sure they have their reasons as
I tend to lean far more to the side of
let nature be nature I mean
hypothetically for example you keep
fixing male lions they stay at the head
of the pride longer than they should and
start mating with their daughters and
that affects the genetics of the whole
population even though that particular
individual might be spectacular was
special but he's only one lion and you
can't look after one line or two lines
need to look after the whole population
the the health of a population is far
more important than one individual in
that population probably into trouble to
say that but anyway well that's what I
believe this is my opinion
Oh exciting times it sounds like Jamie's
lions have woken up and are on the move
that's two males three males my lions
are indeed awake
that's three males do God okay so three
males this just can't the males there
was a female
we've got hey you're in my way four
males
five six males seven males it's a lot of
males possibly even eight I couldn't get
the last one so in that group that just
walked past me there was eight males I
still have encountered obviously I have
encountered the line as first 11 counts
these two which looks like nine male on
ninth male man little one at the back
what are you you look like a female oh
they're little testicles under their
tail I can't tell it's harder to look
when they're a bit younger so what did I
just say - I say nine males that I
confirmed that's crazy
so many males 9 out of 13 I thought
there were a lot of males in that group
but my goodness if I've got that count
right that's a lot of males of the same
age if I've got that count right then
the and gamma pride provided all cubs
survive will only be will only have four
females added to their number when they
these Cubs grow up and they're nine
young males will have to disperse if
they all survive of course and they
probably won't all disperse in one group
nine is uh I mean I could stand
corrected on that who knows how it'll
play out but nine is not a very
sustainable number it's going to forgive
me youngsters I'm going to examine
closely beneath your tail with a pair of
binoculars you're definitely a boy I'm
pretty sure that last one was a female
tardy you want to know why some of them
have spots on their legs like a leopard
all lions have spots when they're born
it's to help to camouflage them and as
they grow up those spots slowly fade but
most lions will never lose them
altogether so if you look at the adult
females but tricky to see but she's
going to get up and accompany the rest
of her that the Cubs now if you look at
her she's got spots on her legs and her
belly still as well no wonder you
haven't bothered all that much this
whole time did you get the biggest
piglet by any chance yes yes you did
you know nearly as hungry as everyone
else somebody lucked out today lucked
out on lunch is this the lioness with a
limp I just want to see if that's not
why she's also stayed behind I didn't
notice any of them limping today and
this morning while I but I did it the
last time I saw them so this morning
they all seemed fine there's chickens
see if she isn't the one that I sold him
thing about a bit earlier
wandah
can you imagine nine male lions they
won't stay I doubt they will stay
together generally speaking when that
does happen and of course it does happen
with certain prides she's walking nah no
she's fine
little bit of us to walk but nothing
serious generally when that does happen
when you get groups of nine males like
that if if I've got that count right
which I think I did then you'll have a
situation where they'll move off in a
group of four and five four three and
six but probably four and five
I'm posh you want to know sorry I'm
having a chuckle cuz I'm thinking about
lions with table manners you want to
know if they catch a large a zebra will
they share nicely not in the state
they're in at the moment no I'm just
gonna wait a Khan sorry I actually can't
turn on the vehicle yet until she's a
bit further past us otherwise we're
gonna give her a fright no not in the
state that they're in they're hungry
they're really really hungry if they're
full and there's plenty of food to go
around and you'll find the growling and
the the snapping and each other is kept
to a minimum but when they're really
hungry like this the it's a bun fight
essentially for who gets what piece of
the meal
by the way in the continuing saga of the
guy who drove into the hole his bumper
just came off while they were trying to
tow him for a guy
okay just gonna catch up a little bit to
these lines see what they get up to
let's send you over back across to a
South Africa you've already seen a water
back here in the Maasai Mara go and have
a look at one in South Africa yes folks
we right near twin dams and we've just
come across some of these FEMA water and
lovely nice view of them swishing their
tails around keeping the flow that they
obviously remember that the females
don't have horns and very easily
identifiable with this lovely shaggy cut
they all right near the water and you
aren't generally funding more than five
to ten kilometres away from water and
that's actually quite far they're
generally within five kilometers of
water but it all depends on how far they
need to go for the grazing now it should
be time for them to start dropping the
young quite soon and the Predators will
be having an opportunity to change their
diets a little bit because they have
they've been filling their boots
another Impala and now I'm sure that
they will be moving across to some of
the Valle de beers zebra and water buck
youngsters in the near future because
they'll also be dropping quite soon so
just lovely to see them feeding here and
remember that water back once they do
you give this they've they've got a
tactic where they actually leave a lot
of the young in a Krish with younger
females
parsa's Bobby making a comment they're
just beautiful I agree absolutely and
especially with that toilet seat ring on
the bottom it's like really a game of
putting the tail on the donkey except
the tail is right in the correct place
so one of those hot afternoons coming
down towards later afternoon starting to
cool down and things are slowly starting
to happen a little bit more movement all
round from the antelope from the
Predators I hear that you did have a
little sneaky peek of husana before he
left the property with Tristan so that's
fantastic news and we're gonna go on our
way towards chitwa Dam so we're gonna be
hitting along this way we're not quite
sure if we're going to have signal in
that area there are little bit of
gremlins around there today so I'm not
going to set you up for us not going
there because it's not for sure so we're
gonna head that way and we see what
happens but there has been a lot of
movement of the leopard in that
particular area in the last few days so
I do want to just cover that area and if
we don't come right there has been talk
of some lions in the Buffalo area so
we've got a little bit of a plan around
that heading towards Chitra and then
maybe towards baffles Hook and in the
meantime we'll also be listening out for
all the other guides if anybody else
hears anything so let's start up let's
carry on down the road while we move
past these water back
hey folks while I continue to search for
any of these big cats Jamie has still
got some of those big cats and I'm sure
she's got lots to tell you about them I
would love to tell you more about them I
can tell you that the lionesses must
have attempted a hunt at some point a
little bit earlier because all of the
zebra and Impala that were gathered
round there have scattered I think
that's why actually the Cubs got up and
they moved in the direction of the
adults they heard the running now it's
quite a cold day today and I promised
her I'd look after Maurice for her so
maurices Maurice is both acting as a
scarf and also tucked up nice and warm
in my jacket I can make sure that he's
fine I've been sending Taylor pictures
of him throughout the course of the
drive Maurice
looking at lions Maurice looking through
binoculars Julia very good very very
valid point because of course the fact
that we are able to enjoy the animals
like this means that it's privileged not
to be abused in any way now Julia is
wondering how close are the vehicles
allowed to get to the animals there is a
Mara Ranger here and there always is it
a busy sighting to make sure that all
rules are obeyed and you're looking at
if I remember correctly a distance of 13
meters at absolute minimum if I remember
that that if I remember if that was the
case
are we always gauge exactly how close
we're going to go obviously there's
situations where you can't help it if an
animal chooses to come and walk right
next to you and lie down next to you
that's that's not sure you know that
really it's nobody's fault and you can
do more damage in terms of upsetting the
animal by then moving then you have by
allowing them to walk in your direction
so as long as you're not allowing them
to break that Spurs personal I why am i
superior izing everything today break
that personal space barrier then you're
absolutely fine so you don't ever let
them touch the vehicle I can't show you
unfortunately because we believe
terribly against the rules but the the
situation unfolding to my left now has
one two three four five six vehicles
plus the guy who's stuck he's out an
arranger and some slightly lost tourists
hilarious I can't show you unfortunately
okay so another exciting it's never
never a dull day in the Masai Mara but
it is time for the Mara team to say of
farewell so we'll send you back across
to my friend back in South Africa
Tristan who has continued his luck and
found use of elephants
I have indeed it's been a lucky
afternoon we've just literally bumped
into animal after animal after animal
it's been quite pleasant actually I've
thoroughly enjoyed being back in Juma
and having a delightful time of just
really not having to work too hard for
anything this afternoon so it seems as
though the Ellie's are back in full
force
almost every road I've driven has got
some sort of sign track dung indication
of an elephant somewhere and now we've
bumped into another large herd that is
slowly but surely moving kind of in a
southeast direction and so if Ralph is
going to head towards chitra Dam I
wouldn't be surprised that this herd
makes an appearance at chitra dam around
sunset that's the kind of direction that
they're taking at the moment and there
it's a beautiful big herd once again
we've got lots and lots of cars they
spread out all through this thicket and
so it's difficult to actually see all of
them now you might notice something
flying around in front of the lens we've
got a whole bunch of insects that are
giving a hard time hold on Ferg let's
get rid of those for you there we go now
they should hopefully be all gone but we
call them monkeys here in South Africa
but they are just different types of
small insects that fly around so a lot
of those will be biting flies often find
them flying around in may accompaniment
of animals so they are attracted to the
animals and you'll find them kind of
moving where they are and they often in
congregate around people and and
particularly lenses for some reason I
don't know what the reason is but you'll
often find camera lenses they attract
them and even screens of TVs or
computers and find that they [ __ ]
towards that area I'd actually love to
know why it is oh it must be a reason
for it maybe there's some sort of
reflection or something that they like
but anyway I mean the aliens are slowly
but surely moving along and like I say
it's quite difficult to judge how many
they actually are here because every way
I look they kind of ones that are
peering like ghosts out of these
thickets it's difficult to see them and
you see that's quite dense to our
western side at the moment but there's
another one in the background there
there's one behind us at the moment I've
seen some that are already to our east
as well so it seems as though it's a
fairly decent grouping and they slowly
but surely are going to make their way
towards check - I think for a bit of a
drink now you can see there's a
beautiful sunset that is developing I
think we can
have a wonderful sunset later because
those cards are going to just get
beautiful colors as the Sun gets down a
little bit lower so Shelley the
elephants will give birth year-round
they're not seasonal breeders like the
impalas are these guys give birth at any
stage of the year and so you'll find
that whether it's winter summer autumn
spring they all are around in the are
little babies at all of those stages so
it's just at any stage and the reason
why that is is because elephants
generally being mixed feeders they're
able to find nutrition in even the most
harshest of conditions as well as the
fact that the little ones suckle for
such a long period of time so they're
sucker for you know over two years and
that means that these little ones are
able to get nutrients even when it's
quite tough and as they grow older then
they become you know adults the mothers
are able to find nutrients even in the
dead of winter by going and digging for
roots and for bark and and they'll know
where there's areas to get food in the
winter months and they can sustain that
milk and still be able to feed the
little one so even though the mothers go
through a tough time
they still able to produce milk and to
be able to feed the babies when they
stall young and developing once they get
over that sort of three-year-old
threshold they're able to feed
themselves and they'll learn from the
mothers and from the other herd members
and they'll be able to then find the
food that they need and the nutrients
that they need I'm gonna see a little
young male of it showing everybody that
he is a boy thank you for that got a
long way to go though before you
intimidate to many others how stayin
that just try and just catch up a little
bit with them so take care you wondering
where the tusks goes into the look
there's a little covering of skin that's
over that top part is that part of the
lip yes it is so what basically happened
is those are modifies incisors so they
start in the inner basically in the jaw
and in the bone structure and they then
start to come out and there is a look
that goes over it so if when they left
their trunk actually if you ever get to
see an elephant with its trunk up in the
air and its mouth open you'll see the
tusks come out from the mouth and that
skin on the sides is just over the top
of it it actually doesn't cover the
tusks all the way around it's just on
top
right now we're going to sit I think a
little longer without ILI's because why
not it's such a wonderful creature to
spend a lot of time with and I'm
thoroughly enjoying being in amongst him
and I believe Ralph has found the best
thing to see and that is in he's going
for a little swim yes folks and we've
we've got these Elysia going for a
lovely swim in the heat of the day Wow
absolutely awesome to what the
youngsters all playing they've had a
fabulous time heading towards the
holiday season and it looks like the
elephants are in the holiday spirit as
well and up in front have been chasing
off the Egyptian geese and it's been a
lovely little sighting this with these
individuals the matka back in the water
logs out the way strutting his stuff yes
that is a mile off you know that is a
female in the way here folks they are
making their way towards us
once again once elephants shot at
they're in a bit of a boisterous mood
don't want to get in their way and the
idea is for us not to be changing the
behavior in any way whatsoever so I
don't want to be in their way especially
when you can sort of see that they're
coming in your general direction I can
now they've turned a little bit so it's
going to and a little bit more out of
their way as well see how they're
reacting towards the Egyptian geese we
don't want them to act the same way with
us coming our way but as you can see
there in a very boisterous me it's
starting to throw some sand over
themselves so they might stop but it's
just a bit of a wall of elephants coming
our way and we don't want to tempt fate
give them the space to their art of way
and we should be fun
so and the hippos off to the right of
these elephants as they make their way
towards us have also been having a
little bit of a orgy bhaji so
everybody's been having a little bit of
a confrontational day I'm not really in
the mood to confront either of them
hippos or elephants so they can by all
means make their way in whatever
direction they want I will give them the
right-of-way and they'll just come out
and I've started throwing dust over
themselves stop now and starting to feed
a little bit on these on these plants it
almost looks like it's these devil
thorns but I'll have a look now in a
minute yellow flowers it's pioneer
pioneer plants all over this disturbed
area and they've got its quite green
foliage on them with yellow flowers and
in a minute I'm just gonna check what
they are see there's a couple of young
bull elephants in the group just keep my
eye on them there's no real big Bulls
here they are making me way across and
as I've said folks if they start making
their way towards me you know sometimes
the youngsters can be a little bit
boisterous and then I obviously bring
the adults with them look at that
there's a bit of an interaction there
was between the elephant and hippos
young bull didn't really like those
hippos being too close to him okay mommy
don't mean any harm and we well out of
your way thank you very much
that's fantastic as they're all march
past us sometimes they can just have a
bit of a look at you just to check that
you don't mean any danger and if they
continue I've hit it off round aside and
while these hippos now start to display
wow look at that
so hippos generally when the elephants
are making a bit of a noise behind us I
don't know if you heard that a little
bit of a trumpet don't know if that was
the matriarch which was the biggest of
the elephants there that female oh if it
was that young male who was being a bit
boisterous towards there the hippos but
the hippos would not open their mouths
like we saw that one I think we caught
the end of it as he was this I don't
know if it's a male or female they but
they will both do it that open their
mouths almost like a big yawn that's
more of a dominance display or the bit
of an aggression towards each other they
showing each other how wide their mouths
can open or how big the gape is the one
who's got the biggest mouth and the
biggest gape is normally the one that
ends up being the dominant one if they
don't back down just from the sight of
it and they can then and end up fighting
which I think might have happened to
that mummy with the little youngster
because and it seemed like it had been
caused by another hippo so it might have
been a small altercation
number of birds flying Martin's chicken
no it's just trying to see nothing
closely they move so fast it's moving
three hundreds of them I'm just checking
in my book a little bit just to see
which is what it's looking at looks like
it could be you know I all looked black
to me but I'm not quite sure that
African black Swift area it's quite
difficult folks to see they're obviously
old little black dots a whole host of
them to belittle Swift's or black
Swift's African palm Swift's a little
bit more a they're quite interesting
because they the palms worst I mean and
I'm not by any means saying that these
are them but quite ingenious because
they literally stick the eggs on the
inside of palm leaves and the hang
babies when they hatch they literally
immediately hang as well so a friend of
mine was actually looking after a couple
of little baby Swift's and I got to see
how they actually hang even from that
tiny little chick stage you even in
captivity you just put a stick over a
box and the little Swift's will hang
upside down from this from the stick so
they're totally dependent on hanging for
when they rest otherwise they maintain
flight and staying on the wing
they eat on the wing and they do most
things on the wing they even drink and
that's what they're doing and that they
were doing a minute ago a lot of them
were swooping down and just taking a
little drink and they do have quite a
special hinge on the bottom part of
their jaw which enables them to drink
that speed like that because you can
imagine the force of it as they scoop
that water if if it wasn't able to hinge
they would literally snap that bottom
part of the jaw off so quite important
for them to be able to shift that and
it's obviously be able to do the little
scoop okay folks we're going to start up
and move along the damn wall of Chitra
dam and then we're gonna go around
towards the airstrip and it's getting
that time of day when the lipids are
starting to move around and there has
been some in that area we're in the area
that I did see her sauna
yesterday evening so we're going to now
go and look for some other ones maybe we
can find tomba and apparently he has
been in the area to never know let's go
and have a look just gonna go in the
same direction that those elephants
walked
alright folks we're losing signal so
let's cut back to Tristan and see what
he is up to now I believe Ralph has had
a beautiful time a trip to daminion is
the best time to be there as is it where
we are the Sun is just getting to that
time of the day where it becomes golden
in color and with the cards that we've
got at the moment the clouds are just
filtering it out and making the lights a
lot softer than what it actually appears
and with a bit of green that we've got
after the rains it really is a beautiful
scene just watching these elephants that
are taking on a more yellow orange color
now because of the light as they goes
through these thickets and just feed
slowly on their way towards the east
it's been amazing just to sit here
because we've sat in quite in relative
silence and just hear them feeding and
moving all around you is just one of the
most wonderful and special things in the
world so Cathy from Ohio you wondering
if I've seen my girl Fang yet no I
haven't there's a couple girls that I
need to catch up with in the next few
days and Fang is most definitely one of
them
I know everyone was super relieved to
hear that she was back at Jimin it was a
matter of time I know a lot of people
thought that maybe we were you know we
didn't have any information and that
maybe something had happened to her but
an individual that sort of well
recognized with a tusk that shape and
the size that she was she would have
been cited somewhere in terms of if she
had died so somebody would have found
her we would have heard of a big
elephant carcass with that Fang in there
all that tusks that grows backwards and
it would have been easy to kind of
follow where she would have been so I
wasn't too concerned it just took a lot
longer for it to come back then I
initially thought so I'm super happy
that she's back in this area I don't
know I know James saw her but I haven't
seen the footage and I know that Ralph
has saw her this afternoon but what I
saw one or two photographs and what
surprised me is it looks as though she
was on her own now Fang generally was
always in a very large herd so it will
be interesting just to see if she is
part of all these groups of elephants
that have arrived at Juma I absolutely
shocked at how many elephants we've seen
this afternoon literally we've seen
elephants absolutely everywhere it's
been come round the road and they're
there not that I'm complaining it's the
best thing in the world to have lots of
Baileys around or instead I was saying
to
when we have elephants we seem to have
lots of leopard as well and so maybe
that recipe will carry on for the next
couple weeks it's a great recipe to have
there's nothing better than both of
those animals for me anyway I like to
spend time with both of those kind of
species and so it's really good to come
back to a lot of them and I hope that
I'll catch up with Fang fairly shortly
and the other female or lady that I
would like to catch up with fairly soon
is Tandy so the two of them that will be
my mission over the next few weeks is to
try and find those two individuals and
spend as much time as I can with both of
them I absolutely love Fang and the herd
that she was a part of it was an amazing
experience to be there when that whole
sort of scenario played out
Rhianna you wondering if elephants will
ever eat bones and I think you said
birds etc so not that I've ever seen
they do pick up bones from time to time
so you will see and then going past a
carcass and they'll pick it up with a
trunk and sometimes they'll even put it
towards their mouth but it's not very
common at all and that's generally if
it's an elephant carcass I haven't seen
them doing it with anything else I've
seen them walk right past buffalo
skeletons I've seen them all passed in
parlor skulls all those kind of things
but it seems as though when they get to
a point where they have another elephant
that's to pick it up and they put it
towards their mouth I don't think they
actually gained any nutrients from it
like something like a giraffe would win
giraffe practices osteo failure when
they put bones in their mouth and they
suck on them and to gain calcium content
I don't think it's the same with the
Ellie's I think it's more of a intrigue
and they trying to work out if there's
maybe some sort of a scent or something
that they can use to figure out what
went on there I've seen it only with
other elephants skeletons and down near
triple-a there's an area as you go
towards the airstrip if you're coming
from the dam side on the eastern side of
the lodge there was an elephant that
died there and that elephant decomposed
over the the months and it was
absolutely fascinating to watch the
elephants coming past that skeleton and
their carcass and and the the amount of
touching and maneuvering of those bones
that took place was absolutely
phenomenal but anyway we're going to
probably sit a little longer without at
least the light is just getting better
and better and we've got such a
beautiful view of the sunset that's
about to happen but I believe Ralph is
got a bird so before it flies away
let's go across to him and see the
majestic beauty of Africa
thanks Justin absolutely we do have a
wonderfully beautiful bit and the very
iconic and special bird as well african
fish eagle and it's just sit down on the
edge of the dam wall and he's looking
like he wants to catch some fish so
we've just stopped and we want to see if
he is potentially eyeing up some prey in
the water he's looking in the direction
of the hippos as well but there might be
some fish moving in the area because
he's looking very intently possibility
that he takes to the wing and stretches
out those talons and grabs a fish on his
way through but just after certain white
maybe he's just wanting to go down for a
drink that's also possible always
looking like they wanted to chase prey
he's just doing a little bit of feather
maintenance the shifting his feathers
around running his ball through them as
well it's important for birds constantly
to be maintaining their feathers and I
usually molt up to three times a year so
they get a whole new set of feathers but
they do work their way through that
they're not dropping all the feathers
all at once as you could imagine it
would make flying a little bit difficult
to make them look rather naked and just
behind him a double pendant clever just
ran off and he needs to be careful as
well because this fish ego will not only
eat fish I do eat birds as well they're
like reptiles I've seen them eating
monitor lizards and maybe even baby
crocodiles so they will eat all sorts
not only fish and in some places they're
hot to eat fish at all it all depends on
their environment and you don't always
find him eating
fish it's a very iconic and beautiful
and amazing to watch when they do
actually go fishing stretching those
talons out and grabbing this out the
water but it needs to be quite a
specialized but of hunting that because
the fish need to be right near to the
surface when he is able to do that so
and he needs to be able to see them for
a prolonged period on the surface too
and Byron making a lovely quorum comment
one of the wild earth presenters saying
that it looks like a beautiful afternoon
on Juma absolutely Byron it's a
fantastic day it's been lovely and hot
but we've had lots of movement of
elephants and hopefully we've gonna
we're gonna see a little bit more of the
lipids as well as the Sun starts dipping
tristin did see her sauna if you didn't
see that now folks I mean a little bit
of two minds because I don't know if I
should be starting up and moving towards
this fish eagle because I think I might
disturb him so we might have to just sit
and wait a little bit and see what he's
gonna do because I'd hate to changed the
behavior of him unnecessarily and if we
do change of place we might actually
miss this bird flying down and
attempting a catch we're gonna continue
sitting here and hopefully we see this
fish eagle take to flatten do a bit of
hunting but in the meantime let's go
over to Tristan who's got a little beak
Rowley to show you
I do indeed I have a very pretty beetle
that is just sitting and enjoying the
afternoon sunshine as much as we are but
I can't seem to figure out exactly what
it is the angle that we've got is not
that ideal in terms of what the beetle
looks like is I've just got its back in
with its legs it's almost got a very
rounded back to it now I know that we do
get milkweed leaf beetles that have a
greenish coppery tinge to the back which
it could be the shape is right for that
it's not one of the emerald dung beetles
that we get they are a lot different in
terms of the shape of the actual beetle
itself now I'm just trying to look
through my beetle book or not my beetle
book but my book of insects should I say
because maybe just maybe the answer lies
somewhere in the hour so thought maybe
it was a jewel beetle but it's not that
it doesn't have the right sort of look
for a jewel beetle so I'm not 100% sure
what it is maybe some of you out there
might know
what it is oh it does look dung beetle
ish now that it's turning a little bit
doesn't it so let's try and have a
little look quickly because there is an
emerald colored dung beetle that we get
here and small green dung beetle is what
its name looks like but I can't see the
heat nicely to see but this is what
we're talking about is this little guy
over here it's got that right kind of
shape although the back legs seem a
little short on this particular beetle
maybe I'll have to go and have a little
look but it's the right color Asian it's
got this emerald kind of color and it's
much like any of the other dung beetles
you see the Marten about and I recently
was in a park not too far from
Johannesburg in the northwestern
province of South Africa and they were
these guys were absolutely everywhere
the green dung beetles and the small
green dung beetles they were all over it
and so it might be one of those but it
just doesn't seem like the right shape
whether I see its turning its face
towards us now hold on let's see maybe
we can try and reposition ourselves so I
can actually see what the head looks
like it might hope you know
identification of our beetle now I know
it's just a little beetle and these
things don't seem and that's important
but I love trying to ID these little
things and try and work out exactly what
these beetles are there we go you see
it's come out onto the open so it's
actually sitting third you need a hand
with that so you should be able to get
it up a little bit food there we go
straight in and then just you're laughs
there we go so now it's come out onto
the edge there now it's not a dung
beetle that's for sure it's got it
different here does it beetle I don't
know it looks dung beetle ish maybe you
guys at home can help me but I think
small drunk beetle is small green dung
beetle is what we are looking at it
seems right cuz can't see the shovel on
the head like they normally gets either
way it's a beautiful creature it's an
emerald emerald green color and when the
Sun was shining on it it was glistening
less green and was absolutely beautiful
particularly against that drab dry
background that it's on at the moment
lady bird you wondering what type of
lady birds do we get here in the sabi
sands well we get I think three
different species if I'm not mistaken
there are lots in South Africa within
the sabi sands we had three different
species and I'm just trying to find them
in my book so I can show you which ones
we get now of course they are very
similar and so a lot of the time they
just get branded as the same thing even
though they are different so if we have
a look yeah we go
Lady Bird that we get and I wonder if
it's maybe the same as what you get is
in this particular individual over here
so we do see them they're not commonly
occurring in this area it's not as
common as some of the other sort of
similar type insects that we get but
they do sometimes show themselves this
is the other one that we get which is a
lot more common I've seen this one a lot
more it doesn't actually have a common
name at all so it's not referred to you
as a lady bird bug but it is of the same
family and looks very similar it's just
a lot more radon it's in the one at the
bottom which is the Lady Bird bug that
we're talking about but you do get these
guys here
very seldom is what I say is not that
often that you'll see them anyway I'm
not 100% sure what's our little insect
who is it's now flown away so maybe some
of you got screenshots and you can help
me out and identify it right now I'm
going to leave our Ellie's because
they've drifted off into the bush into
the thickets we're going to try and see
if we can pull a little rabbit out the
Hat with tiny at some point and while we
do that I believe Ralph has found
something rather stripey to look at
here's Justin strappy and a donkey in
pajamas virtual plains zebra a lovely
stallion here all on his own and as such
his behavior is also that of being not
as skittish as a group of them
and he's so photogenic it is fantastic
to see that just off to the left of him
approaching the waterhole is a water
buck as well that's a nice bull water
buck starting to get that lovely
curvature in his horns he looks like he
might be coming down for a drink
as I would do too if I was an animal in
his heat decided against that
i doesn't like that Spotty's i don't
look for a better spot to come down
lovely reflection of him as he goes fast
little to no wind and just in front of
us the Zebras started to graze a little
bit here we go lovely nice back end of
zebra and remembering that we do get
different zebra in South Africa now we
get a couple of different ones up in the
Mora as well and of the gravy zebra and
the virtual zebra up there to you the
plain zebra we get the Cape mountain
zebra and up into Namibia you have the
the Hartman's mountain zebra but their
stomachs are white and I have a dewlap
and they don't have that lovely shadows
drop that you're seeing there on the
rump of this all the ramp going down the
legs and up the torso of this virtual
zebra
Julie are asking a very pertinent
question do the Stallions usually stay
on their own or not that I heard that it
can happen especially with the younger
males that haven't established
themselves a harem and generally the
males will move with the herd the
youngsters they'll stay with mommies
heard that has been established by a
stallion and then once he comes of age
that stallion will chase him off and
then he can wander around on his own for
a little while until he can challenge
for a harem himself and they're not
territorial but they I do protect a
group of females at present maybe he's
just he's enjoying the alone time hasn't
got himself a group of ladies just yet
so he's still in that movable mode and
water back also making his way towards
the zebra is also having a quiet feed
and beautiful animals those are as we
saw the females but earlier
Kathy in a higher asking what and slap
have curled horns I believe I think the
question was well we have quite a few
different of the of the Antelope and as
they curl yes we do start to be able to
tell the age now with the water back
once they get a full curl it's it's
normally at about 50 months so if you
can do the maths on net with CUDA also
with it with the curls in a kudos horns
you start to get the third curl at about
18 months break their horns start
curling a lot earlier in comparison to
the water back sorry I'll just keep
looking a little bit away from the
camera because there's a great go away
bird which is alarm calling just off to
our right but so a lot of the the
antelope you can tell the edge from the
curvature in the horns as with the the
Springbok there's also curl and a lovely
story that I do have about the antelope
and how they got the shapes of their
horns well initially all the animals
used to feed out on the plains and it
was the Lions and the Predators were
with him as well and none of them at
horns and and the Lions also ate grass
too now one day the Lions one line in
particular he got a taste for meat he
tried to eat a little Impala and he
loved the taste so much that he started
to aggressively chase all sorts of
antelope and he told all of his friends
and so all the lions started to get a
very nice taste for meat now the
antelope had no way of defending
themselves so they were a little bit
perturbed by this whole thing with with
the Lions starting to eat all of them as
we see some warthogs there that have
just been in the water so the antelope
were very perturbed about them being
eaten by all these lines so they went to
the wise owl and I said to the wise owl
we need a way of being able to defend
ourselves
so the
I'll said to them you all need to go
down to the water hole on the full moon
as we're having this evening the super
moon you need to go down to the water
hole and you need to go in the water
hole and during the night you will grow
some horns that you will be able to
defend yourselves with against the lions
but you must stay in the water hole
until the full Sun of the next day
returns because at such time your horns
will sit and they'll be lovely and
straight and spiky and they'll be able
to help you defend yourself as a weapon
against the Lions so the Antelope listen
to the wiles ow and all of them went
down to the waterhole and they lay in
the water and they started to grow the
horns now there were some different
reactions to them growing their horns so
a few of them got very excited and as
the Sun came up and I started to see the
the horns they started to run out in
excitement with his new addition to
their body and such wonderful things on
their heads that they could now use to
defend themselves but they weren't
listening to the wiser